good morning believe nation today's
message is do what you love over to you
future I was called the goo we're known
in the studio and nothing else matters
where the news I you got this love for
something that you think about you sleep
and you dream and you wake up and you
breathe it you want to live it is so
many options as many ways to blow up as
many ways to be known and to get success
and to be successful it is about picking
their way to fit you so here's the path
for so many successful people you get an
interest in something you want to try
something so you try it you suck at it
but you really enjoyed it so you come
back and you do it again and you try to
get better and you improve you come back
you suck a little bit less but you're
still really bad but you love it so much
you have to keep doing it even though it
doesn't make sense even though you're
not seeing any kind of return you just
love doing it even though people are
telling you that you're crazy even
though your parents or your friends are
saying what the heck are you doing to
make any sense in the world you have to
keep doing it because you love the
process and slowly here's what happened
you get a little bit better you get a
little bit better you work harder you
get a little bit better now suddenly
you're average you're just average but
you're still spending time you're still
putting effort you're still hustling to
try to get better if you still have the
people around you saying that you're
crazy that you're never going to make it
that the numbers are against you the one
I do the smarts a practical thing to do
and go in that other room so we're doing
this thing because now you're just
average like I gotta keep doing it I
love it to do more you practice harder
you hustle you hustle you hustle you
grind up more now you're good now you're
good now may be made even a little bit
of money off of it whatever this hobby
passion thing is of yours and you still
get the people saying that you're never
going to make it like you just make it a
little bit of money you know how you get
ever turn that thing into a career it's
never going to happen for you there's no
way look look at all these massively
talented people who are ahead of you you
think you're going to compete with those
guys you think you're going to win in
that game it's not going to happen but
you love it you love the process and so
you work harder and you
to you to practice and you get good and
you get better and you improve a new
improve and you improve and now you're
above average you're better than good
you're certain to get great maybe you're
starting to almost make a full time
income from this thing and people will
still look at you cycle just the way you
you're still doing this why are you
still doing this you spent these years
working on this thing you should have
been way ahead and said the career now
you're paying your bills but you're
never going to be that great thing what
do you do you love the process so you
keep working at keep worked in it and
you get great and you get amazing and
then you win that's the success story
for almost every successful person that
we profile they sucked at the start but
they loved the process and they kept
going and they improve and they got
better that's how you win if you feel
this thing inside you where you love the
process of doing something don't be so
concerned with how it's going to work
out because quite often they do that you
have in your head is not how it's going
to work out the end result is not what
you're chasing the process is what
you're chasing when I started this
YouTube channel it wasn't to become
YouTube famous that wasn't part of my
goal I need to know how it's going to
make money off of this have Mickey money
and helping entrepreneurs the first
thing I did was three people showed up
to a free event how you're going to make
one day off something if you can't get
more than three people to come to a free
event and the world opened up to me in a
way that I never thought possible I
never got to get a book deal with
penguin Random House and I was thought
to be asked to join boards of directors
in different companies and get paid to
do it never thought of worked with big
brands who would then hire me out to
work with them on projects and ever
thought these things would happen and it
wasn't even on my radar as in my
business model or my plan what I wanted
to do is create amazing content to help
entrepreneurs helping entrepreneurs
feeds my soul and I had to find a way to
do it even if I never made any money is
because it has that passion information
I ended up making money that's how it
works to find the saying that you love
doing you have insane passion towards
and figure out a way to do that as much
as possible practice as hard as you can
even if you absolutely suck at the start
because that's the thing that's going to
make you come alive that's the thing
we're going to deliver insane value to
the world that
point when you get really good at it and
the only way to get there is the
practice and practice and practice and
practice and practice and stop listening
to the people around you who say that
you'll never make it you can't do it so
the question is today guys is what do
you love leave in the comments curious
to find out I was going to give a quick
shout out to James Mitchell James thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book hear one word really means a lot
same and appreciate the support and I
hope you're enjoying the read thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you don't forget seems to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
sister said if I did that not stopped
going to school and that's all I did was
hanging the hood that I wasn't gonna be
here today mm-hmm but that's why I still
hang with the same people that I was
whipped back in the hood and I changed
my mentality I don't think the same way
i was when i was there open my mind up I
thought broader I thought outside of my
horizons like you gotta think outside
the box mm-hmm because that's the only
way you're gonna get out when you
trapped in the shop you really mentally
trapped in the trap and it's me be like
man I want to make sure my people just
know that that's just not the end of
your life like if somebody T statistic
is not true you're gonna fight
statistics and go to the next level
night so chicser said I wouldn't even be
here talking to you right now if I
would've listened to them and tell them
how my life would have been they say one
out of ten people they gonna be like
this one nine out of ten black males
that they do this live this way they
gonna do this you know I'm saying is no
way around it they gonna tell you is
nowhere around so if you in the hood
right now you're standing on the block
every day then police is run by that old
lady that's looking at you just calling
the police on you yeah the people who
ran by just looking at you like laying
nests in your pants sagging I think you
ain't gonna never be nothing they think
you're gonna be like that for the rest
of your life like who is the person to
tell you that you're gonna be standing
on this block all your life supposed to
be a point in your life where you on the
beer for you get yourself a year to you
from here it don't do no good for you to
be here all your life and you spending
majority of your life 22 hours I showed
a trying to prove you the harder than
the hood you come from the Jews boiling
as you when you came home from the
hospital you went to the hood you know
I'm saying so you don't live your whole
life this way for all your life you
deserve to live in a different
neighborhood better yourself for 34
years out of your whole life when you've
been living this way probably some dudes
been living that way for 20 years 23
years been in the hood since they came
home from the from the house building
they still trying to prove to the hood I
hardly is in the end I'm not making it
because they never did a self you got to
prove to yourself that you want more
than which off at the end of the day
went out for my first song when I first
made my hair
what I can do you know I'm saying I know
the type of artists that I am I know the
caliber of music that I can come with
and i know i can continue to do it i was
born to make music and when you gotta
give for something you just got to know
how to utilize it and when I found the
way to utilizing or just make the most
of my opportunity i know i have to be up
my art as i have to stay in the studio
and create all the time you know i'm
saying if i was to lay off and i go to
the studio there in autos he said she
said it might would have came through
but I know the work that i was playing
in fiction says is right well you ever
been successful you don't know where she
keeps insisting happy how to be
successful you know the right moves
you're making in every move that you're
making a beast riser and you just
achieving something that you made
clothes for yourself you said goes and
your cheese goes at end of the day you
still sits down this hot when you reach
a certain plateau and then you know man
I got to go to that next level you know
I'm saying we want to be successful
night so since it's different from other
people you know you need you you know
like success for me and just making
music the nexus s been successful is
like winning a Grammy your aunty